ILLEGALLY AND THE BEST PART OF
THE DAY I'M.
OKAY MANY HUNDRED HAVING TAX IS
IN SESSION --
ITEM NUMBER ONE AS BE SIXTY SIX
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIFTEEN A
SEVEN IS ON OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR
.
SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SEE ANOTHER YEAR.
IT WILL BE LIKE START ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
MISTER WALLACH CENTER MORE LIKE
WHICH YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW HOW EFFICIENT WE ARE
HERE REVENUE AND IT'S A GREAT
BILL.
THE I CAN'T MOVE IT YET BUT IT'S
A GREAT BELCH.
AND I GUESS I JUST KEEP IT
REALLY SHORT I..
AMONG REVENUE COMING GOVERNOR TO
FINANCE THE SENATE SIDE IN WHOM
DOING A LOT WITH THESE TAX
CREDITS AND I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
STRATIFICATION.
SEE IF THEY'RE EFFICIENT IF
THEY'RE EFFECTIVE IF THEY'RE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING.
AND SO THAT'S OVER ASKING FOR
WITH THIS BILL WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS JUST TO
GET.
MORE DETAILS WE CAN.
MEASURE IT BETTER AND THEN
MANAGE IT BETTER.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I I LOVE FINDING OUT MORE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
JUST.
TO RESPECTFULLY.
COMMENT THAT YOU RUN AN AMAZING
MEETING THAT IT CHAIR.
BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE MY VOTE
AND YOU KNOW GET SOME MORE DATA
TO HELP US OUT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION NO
THANK YOU FOR A GREAT BELL
THERE'S NO AMENDMENTS I ONLY
HAVE A COMMITTEE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
VERY MUCH THANKS SO MUCH OF A
GOOD EVENING.
WE HAVE IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
MS HYLAND WE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
GROWTH HERE [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
GRAY MELINDA'S.
MULLIN QUIRK HERE [inaudible]
REAVIS [inaudible]
KING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
CLAIRE FOR THAT THEY MOVED THE
MORALE BILL THEY MORE LOCKED
BILL.
YEAH.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IN A SECOND AT ON S.
B. --
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE WHEN.
BECAUSE I WANTED TO COLOR OFF.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE I BOROUGH.
GROW AYE CHIU. TO I GRAY
MELINDA'S.
MULLIN QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REAVIS.
US AYE TING.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT. TO REMOVE
CONSENT.
YES HURRY TURN.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS HIGHLY COLOR ALL
[inaudible]
BURKE I GROW.
WELL I CHIU.
CHU I'VE GRAY MELINDA'S MULLIN.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REAVIS.
BEAVIS AYE TING [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
THE PALATE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
[inaudible]
YES.
WE HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR HE
HEARING.
SENATOR ARE YOU PUT MANY.
MOVING A FILE ITEM TO S. B..
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY OPEN
[inaudible]
READY.
MEMBERS HOW ARE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START.
BY TAKING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED.
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOROUGH WORK IN
THEIR HARD WORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH --
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY FOUR
WOULD --
PROVIDE A TAX BENEFIT --
TO TO THE DEDICATED STATE
SERVICE MEMBERS.
WHO HELP PROTECT --
AND DEFEND CALIFORNIA DARREN --
CRISIS OF THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT
--
INCOME RECEIVED BY THE NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBER FROM A STATE INCOME
TAX.
WHEN THAT INCOME IS DERIVED FROM
THE EMERGENCY STATE ACTIVE DUTY
--
STATUS --
ONE CALLED IN THE SERVICE THERE.
E. S. EIGHTY STATUS THE ACT OF
OUR MILITARY SERVICE THE COMMAND
OF THE GOVERNOR.
AND THEIR MISSIONS INCLUDE STATE
EMERGENCY SUCH AS WILDFIRES
WHICH WE JUST HAVE FLOODS WHICH
YOU HAD THOSE TWO EARTHQUAKES
AND OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS.
I AM CURRENTLY WON THE NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS SERVES UNDER E. S.
A. D. HERE SHE IS PAID DIRECTLY
BY THE STATE.
AND THEN --
THIS INCOME IS FULLY TAX BY THE
STATE'S SPIKE AFFECT THESE.
ARE SERVICE MEMBERS ARE
PROVIDING A STATE APPROVED DEAN
IS COLLECT TAXES ON THE INCOME
SP -- NINE
TWENTY FOUR WOULD HONOR AND AT
THE DEDICATION.
OF THESE PUBLIC SERVANTS FOR
CALL AWAY FROM THEIR HOMES AND
FAMILIES IN RESPONSE TO STATE
CRISIS ARE WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA.
JAMES MOVIE.
MOVE THE BILL I'D LIKE HALF
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION.
HE SAID THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS A SPORT WHEN FOR ME
ARE OFTEN GAY ARE GOOD EVENING
NOW A?
MAN CHAIR IN MEMBERS NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS ARE DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS SERVANTS THAT
PERFORM ESSENTIAL DUTIES FOR THE
STATE AND BRA RECENTLY PROVED
THAT WITH THEIR ASSISTANT FIRE
FIGHTING.
AND MASSIVE FLOODS --
IN COULDN'T IN THIS LAST
CALENDAR YEAR CURRENTLY NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
TAX RELIEF. FOR INCOME MARROW
WHILE SERVING DURING A STATE
EMERGENCY.
SB TWENTY FOUR A NIGHT TWENTY
FOUR WOULD CHANGE THIS BY
EXEMPTING INCOME RECEIVED BY
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBER FROM THE
STATE INCOME TAX WHEN THE INCOME
HIS ARM.
DO ARE DERIVED MERGES STATE
ACTIVE DUTY.
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD FALLS
INTO THE UMBRELLA OF THE ACTIVE
MILITIA MILITIA ACCORDING TO
SECTION ONE TWENTY OF THE
MILITARY VETERANS STRODE.
THE NATIONAL GUARDS CALLED INTO
SERVICE UNDER THE THREE DISTINCT
US OF STATUSES.
EMERGENCY STATE OUT FOR DUTY
TITLE THIRTY TWO AND TITLE.
TEN WHEN CALLED INTO SERVICE ON
EMERGENCY STAY THAT COULD DO
STATUS THE ACT OF MILITIAS OR
NATIONAL GUARD SERVES AT THE
COMMAND OF THE GOVERNOR.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE
PAID BY THE STATE AND THEIR
MISSIONS INCLUDE STATE EMERGENCY
SUCH AS WILDFIRE FLOODS
EARTHQUAKES AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS.
UNDER THE TITLE THIRTY TWO
STASSEN NASH BARS UNDER
GOVERNOR'S COMMAND THE BAY BY
THE FOR IT.
BUT PAID BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR MISSIONS
INCLUDING TRAINING AND OTHER
FEDERAL YOU BRING AUTHORIZED
DUTIES.
UNDER TITLE TEN THE NATIONAL
GUARD IS ALSO A FEDERAL PAYROLL
FOR DUTIES PRIMARILY RELATED TO
OVERSEAS DEPLOYMENT.
A ONE THAT WHEN ACTIVATED ON
EMERGENCY STATE AFTERNOON STATUS
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS WHO
RESPOND TO THE MOST DIRE
SITUATIONS AND WHAT.
WHEN EXISTING EMERGENCIES
RESPONSE?
RESOURCES ARE INSUFFICIENT GET
THE JOB DONE THERE ARE CALLED
AWAY FROM THEIR DAY JOBS AND
STABLE SOURCES OF INCOME TO
PLACE OUR LIVES IN IMMEDIATE
DANGER FOR THE GOOD OF THE OF
THE STATE.
AS MIDNIGHT TWENTY FOUR IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS REWARDING THEIR
FORTITUDE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I DON'T WELL WE'LL TAKE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IN THE MODE ASK
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IF THAT'S WHEN IT WHEN
I OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO MY PROBLEM WITH THIS IN ANY
OTHER BILL THAT RELIES ON
DEDUCTIONS.
IS THAT PEOPLE MAKE VERY LITTLE
MONEY.
WILL GET NO BENEFIT.
BUT IF YOU FOR EXAMPLE HAVE A
SPOUSE MAKING A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A YEAR.
YOU GET A LARGE BENEFIT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN A HIGH TAX
BRACKET.
SO THIS HELPS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RICH THE MOST AND THE POOR THE
LEAST.
AND I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE WAY TO DO IT I THINK IF YOU
REALLY WANTED TO HELP THESE
FOLKS.
ANOTHER WAY TO DO THIS WOULD BE
TO GET A LINE ON IT IN THE
BUDGET.
SIMPLY SAY ARM SHE YOU KNOW
THESE PEOPLE ARE CALLED UP BY
THE GOVERNOR.
WILL PAY THEM SOME ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT WHILE THEY'RE ON DUTY.
THEN YOU'D BE HELPING EVERYBODY
THE SAME.
BUT HERE YOU'RE HELPING THE RICH
THE MOST SO I JUST CAN'T SUPPORT
IT HOOK THAT.
THAT'S A THAT'S OKAY I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHERE YEAR EMPIRICAL
DATA WILL COME FROM THE SAY
THESE PEOPLE ARE RATCHET IF
THEY'RE KINDA SPREAD.
OVER BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT.
NO BUT SOME OF THEM WERE RICH
SOME OF THEM ARE MAKING A GOOD
INCOME THERE MAKING GOOD INCOME
ON THEIR OWN JOBS THEIR SPOUSES
YOU'RE MAKING GOOD INCOME.
THERE IN A HIGH TAX BRACKET THEY
WOULD GET A VERY LARGE BENEFIT
SOMETHING LIKE TEN TWELVE AND
13%.
WHERE IS SOMEBODY WHO MAKES VERY
LOW INCOME?
WE GET ALMOST NO BENEFIT OR
PERHAPS NO BENEFIT.
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE HELPING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY A LOT IN THE PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T MAKING MUCH MONEY.
YOU'RE REALLY NOT HELPING AT ALL
WHERE YOU ARE.
PEOPLE MAKE LESS MONEY IF YOU
HELP THEM A LITTLE BIT IT HELPS
BUT I I CAN CARRY REALLY NOT
BEAT THEM AND I PAY TAXES AT ALL
OR IF THEY DO WHICH IS. 234%
WERE IS PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY 101213% THAT'S MY
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL NO PROBLEM
AYE CHOQUET.
THANKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
MISTER MARONEY THINK YOU FOR
BILLING BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD --
EIGHT AND I DO IT.
I DON'T I HAVING SERVED --
IN THE MILITARY HAVING HAS BEEN
NOT THE NATIONAL GUARD BUT IN
YOU KNOW STRAIGHT ACTIVE DUTY --
AND HAVING HAD OPPORTUNITIES --
TO TO WORK WITH NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN AND WOMEN --
I JUST WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
MY GOOD FRIEND --
FROM HAND VERDE THINK.
HAYWARD SORRY HAYWARD --
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF MEN
GUARDSMEN WHO ARE WEALTHY --
THEIR THEIR WHAT THEIR SPOUSE
MAY HAVE --
A DECENT PAYING JOB BUT I THINK
TO HIS POINTS.
IT'S GOING TO HELP EVERYBODY
EVERY LITTLE BIT DOES HELPING
AND ALSO I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET RECALLED
TO ACTIVE DUTY --
YOUR CIVILIAN PAY GOES AWAY.
SO IT'S NOT AS THOUGH YOU'RE
BRINGING IN --
THE BIG BUCKS WHILE YOU'RE YOU
KNOW BEING DEPLOYED FOR THE
STATE -- SO.
WITH WITHOUT I THINK I'D LIKE TO
SECOND THE MOTION I UNDERSTAND
THERE WASN'T ONE I'M JUST TELL
YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR
THE BILL.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THEM.
WE HAVE A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ AND A FIRST OF
MOTION BY PEROT SECOND BY
MELINDA'S ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE AND NOW HIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE.
I THINK YOU THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
AMENDMENT IS TO ADD A TEN YEAR
SUNSET TO THE EXTENSION --
IT THEN GOES TO THE COMMITTEE ON
VETERAN AFFAIRS.
THAT MEANS HAVING TO CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED TO
VETERAN AFFAIRS.
FOR BURKE I GROW.
ROLL AYE CHIU.
CHU I GRAY.
MELINDA'S RELIGIOUS AYE MULLIN
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING GRIEVOUS.
RIVERS I CHIANG [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I THANK YOU GUYS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR S. B..
TEN ZERO SEVEN SENATOR HERTZBERG
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
[inaudible]
IF YOU [inaudible]
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
USUALLY VERY MUCH I'LL BE BRIEF.
THERE ARE MOTION AND A SECOND.
TWO YEAR IN THE SILENT ERA
PELLE.
I NEVER MOVE YOU NEVER MOVED
[inaudible]
SUESS.
I LOVE IT TWENTY YEARS TWENTY
THREE YEARS AGO SAME CHAIR.
SO WE SAW THIS BILL LAST YEAR IT
WAS A MAY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NEW ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WE SAW THIS BILL LAST YEAR A
SPEAKER PROBABLY PUT HIM ATKINS
AND LEADER BATES CARRIED IT.
AND IT GOT CAUGHT UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS --
ISSUE WITH THE END ON THE
ASSEMBLY SORRY.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS ARMED
IN OUR EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
MADAM CHAIR OF COURSE.
BUT IT WAVES STATE LOCAL TAXES
FOR CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS IN
IN WHAT THIS RELATES TO IS THIS
ARM.
ISSUE OF AT CAMP PENDLETON OF
THIS --
VETERANS FACILITY AND
HISTORICALLY FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PAYS THE PROPERTY TO
AND IT PAYS FOR THE COSTS AND AS
A RESULT TO EXEMPT FROM THE
TAXES IN THIS INSTANCE.
THIS FACILITY WAS BUILT BY NOT
FOR PROFIT ENTITY ARE THE
INITIAL BE MEASURE ASKED FOR
RETROACTIVITY AT THE REQUEST OF
THE CHAIR AND HER BRILLIANT
STAFF --
JOKING --
STEATITE THE THE WE WE'VE EXCEPT
IT WASN'T MUCH TO GO FORWARD AS
OPPOSED TO RETROACTIVE HE'S ME
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE A RULE
AGAINST US.
SUCKING UP TO THE CHAIR WOMAN
DURING TESTIMONY RATE NOT
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT OF IT'S A GOOD
ROLL I LIKE THAT.
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T WORK IN THE
SENATE WE LIKE THAT RULE.
ALTHOUGH I SAT MADE SURE ANSWER
LIKE THAT.
OF IS VERY COMMITTEES THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IF ANY
BUSY QUESTIONS HAPPY TO ANSWER
ROB.
IT WE HAD A WITNESS WHO SAT
AROUND ALL DAY HAD COME UP OF
FROM CAMP PENDLETON TO WOULD TO
BE HERE.
AND HE HAD TO LEAVE TO CATCH THE
LAST PLANE OUT SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT IN THE WAITED ALL DAY
LONG SINCE EARLY THIS MORNING
BUT I TOLD THEM IT WAS OKAY TO
GO.
HAPPILY --
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS IN THE
HOUSE --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES ARE PLACING.
AT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WAIT WAIT COMPLEX RIPPING UP.
ALCOHOL GOOD SENATOR ALL THANKS
CHAIRED BY HANDS RIGHT BUT IT'S
A TYPICALLY --
CENTER THANKS SO MUCH FOR ME AS
FOR HOUSE INVOLVED IN THAT BILL
LAST YEAR WITH THE INTREPID
FALLEN HEROES FUND RIGHT NOW
BUILT THE BRAIN INJURY CENTER ON
CAMPUS AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ITS
TO EXEMPT.
THEM AT THE CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS TO BUILD THIS
FACILITY.
AND I THINK IT'S ADMIRABLE THAT
YOU HAVE A NONPROFIT RAISING
PRIVATE DOLLARS AND THEY'RE
GONNA TURN OF SILLY OR THE
GOVERNMENT ANSWER IT WAS A SHAME
I GOT CAUGHT IN.
AN ASSEMBLY SPECIALIZED HERE BUT
THANKS FOR CHAMPION AND AND
OBVIOUSLY GOT MY SPORT SURE
THANK YOU TIME AND AND IT REALLY
IS.
IT ONLY DEALS WITH DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE ISSUES IS QUITE LIMITED
I UNDERSTAND THE POLICY ISSUES
AROUND THIS BECAUSE I CHAIR THE
TAX COMMITTEE.
IN THE OTHER HOUSE --
SO BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
EXCEPTION THAT MAKES SOME SENSE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE A DUCT WORK.
BY.
SO MY CONCERN IS AND IT MAY BE
THAT IT'S FIXED IN THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN.
THAT SOMEBODY ARM.
THE CONTRACTOR COULD BUY A LOT
OF EQUIPMENT.
IT'S BEING USED ON MULTIPLE
SITES.
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE BUYING THEM
AT THE TIME THEY HAVE THIS
CONTRACT THAT THEY MIGHT --
JUST DECIDE TO BUY WHAT THEY
NEED FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS
[inaudible]
SO -- THAT
WAS A CONCERN I HAVE IN THE BILL
--
IF YOU'RE EXCLUDING THEM FROM
ALL SALES TAXES OPPOSED TO JUST
THINGS THAT GO INTO THE
BUILDING.
AND I COULDN'T TELL FROM THE
BILL AND PERHAPS THE CHAIR CAN.
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT MACHINERY THAT WAS
PURCHASED AT THAT TIME AND MIGHT
BE USED IN OTHER --
PROJECTS WAS EXEMPT AND THAT
THAT'S A KEY QUESTION I HAVE
YEAH.
IF ARGUMENT TO THE CHAIR INSISTS
QUESTION BASICALLY THE MEASURE
SAYS THAT THE EXEMPTION IS
LIMITED TO UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE PURCHASES.
AND VETERAN AFFAIRS THAT ARE
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IT IDENTIFIES
QUALIFIED FACILITY THE QUALIFIED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
THAT HAS TO DONATE.
THE ASSET TO THE DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE PURSUANT TO SECTION OF
UNITED STATES CODE OR THE TH
DEPARTMENT OFFENSE I THINK IT'S
PRETTY NARROW.
FAIR QUESTION OPENING QUESTION
BUT IT'S PRETTY NEARLY CRAFTED
OKAY SO THE AND THE HAD IT THAT
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT I THINK I
TO DATE HAVE TO DONATE THE
EQUIPMENT AS WELL.
IN ORDER TO GET THE TAX
EXEMPTION THEY COULD USE THE
EQUIPMENT LATER.
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT AYE AYE
OFFICE IT BUT I THINK THEY CAN
GET UP THEY BUY IT OR DOES ARE
BUT ARE GONNA CERTAINLY DON'T
EVERYTHING GETS DONATED THAT'S
HOW CARRIE BEHIND IT AND THE
GHOST THE NONPROFIT AND THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON THEY GET THE
EXEMPTION SURE.
OKAY AND THE GUYS DON'T TELL
GOVERNOR AND MY CONCERN I'LL BE
UPLOADING AYE.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THAT'S WHAT I DON'T THINK
SO MUCH THINK YOU AND THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE AMENDMENTS --
THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO MAKE
THE EXEMPTION PROSPECTIVE
BEGINNING AS JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WITHOUT WE
HAVE -- DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISSILE WHEN YOU
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE BY BURKE
EYEBROW WILL.
GROW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S AYE
MULLIN QUIRK I QUIRK AYE REAVIS
REAVIS AYE TING.
TING NOT LOADING VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL.
THANK YOU THAT THOSE UP THEY
GONNA CHANGE SO MUCH THANK YOU.
I SENATOR DIED FILE ITEM THREE
SB NINE FIFTY EIGHT TO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. FOR DECADES THE VOTERS IN
THE CITY OF DAY.
HAVE APPROVED LOCAL PARCEL TAXES
TO FUND THE DAVIS JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING
REAFFIRMING A LOCAL COMMITMENT
TO PRIORITIZE IN HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION IN THE COMMITTEE
COMMUNITY.
S. B. NINE FIFTY EIGHT IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE DAVIS JOINT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO ALLOW PARCEL
TAX EXEMPTION. FOR TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN ADDITION TO
SSI RECIPIENTS AND SENIORS THAT
ALSO RECEIVE A PARCEL
TAX-EXEMPTION.
THIS BILL WHICH IS SUPPORTED BY
THE TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE FOR A PUBLIC EDUCATORS
AND SCHOOL STAFF TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY DAVIS WHERE THEY WORK.
AT NO COST TO THE STATE.
THIS FINANCIAL BENEFITIS
IMPORTANT PARTICULARLY MY THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING THE TEACHERS
MY SHOULDER IN ORDER TO LIVE
NEAR THE PLACE TO WORK WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS ALLEN
FERNANDES.
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL SPONSORED
DAVIS JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND BLAIR HOWARD A
TEACHER IN THE DAVIS JOINT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHEN IT IS IN SUPPORT GREAT
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU AYE
MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
ALLEN FERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
DAVIS JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE I SERVE AS
TRUSTEE.
OF MYSELF AND MY FOR THEIR
COLLEAGUES ABOUT VOTED.
FIVE ZERO TO ASK THE STATE FOR
SOME FLEXIBILITY --
WITH OUR LOCAL DOLLARS RAISED BY
VIA --
PARCEL TAX --
I I WANNA KIND ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THAT CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS
THAT EVERTON IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
MANY OF YOUR STAFF.
ON FIRST THING IS THIS AS
SENATOR DODD INDICATED HAS NO
COST TO THE STATE ED AND THE
QUESTION OF WHY DON'T YOU USE
YOUR GENERAL FUND THIS IS OUT OF
OUR GENERAL FUND AND MORE TO THE
POINT IT'S OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND THAT DOESN'T COME FROM THE
STATE.
ALL ON THE OTHER THING IS IS
THAT YOU KNOW UP FOR THOSE WHO
RIDE DON'T CARE GLORIA EXCEPTION
[inaudible]
OF ON THAT ON THAT NOTE I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR YOUR IVA.
AND WE'RE HERE FOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU --
MANY AS BLAIR HOWARD AND I'M A
CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL SOCIAL
STUDIES TEACHER AND DAVIS --
IT WAS A DECADES LONG CHALLENGE
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
BUY A HOME.
IN THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH I
TEACH.
I WAS ABLE TO DO BECAUSE THE
CITY --
DEVELOP SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND MY INCOME FINALLY IMPROVED
--
ENOUGH. TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD A
HOME BUT EVEN WITH ALL THAT. FOR
HOME IN DAVIS --
DAVIS'S LONG VALUE TEACHERS AS
MEMBERS OF THEIR COMMUNITY WITH
EDUCATION TYING THE COMMUNITY
TOGETHER IN SO MANY WAYS.
LIVING IN TOWN AND NOT COMMUTING
TO SCHOOL COMMUTING FROM ANOTHER
TOWN THIS ALLOWS ME TO SPEND
MORE TIM AT MY SCHOOL.
AND WORKING WITH STUDENTS
IMPROVING THEIR LEARNING MOST OF
WHICH HAVE FALLEN BEHIND IT
WOULD NOT EVEN BE ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE IF NOT FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT TIME WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY LESS STATE FUNDING
COMPARED TO SURROUNDING DISTINCT
DISTRICTS HAS LED TO A
COMPENSATION GAP COMPARED WITH
HIGHER --
PAIRED WITH HIGHER HOME PRICES
HAVE PRICED MANY YOUNGER
TEACHERS LIKE MYSELF OUT OF
BUYING A HOME IN THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH WE SERVE.
WE LOSE MANY TEACHERS A YEAR TO
THIS DYNAMIC AND CONSISTENTLY
NEED TO REPLACE TEACHERS --
AND THE NEED TO CONSISTENTLY
REPLACE TEACHERS DISRUPTS
STUDENT LEARNING I LOVE TEACHING
IN DAVIS AND BEING ABLE TO LIVE
IN TOWNS KEPT ME THERE DESPITE
KNOWING I COULD MAKE THOUSANDS
MORE DOLLARS COMMUTING OR LIVING
IN ANOTHER COMMUNITY.
BUT I ALSO KNOW MANY TEACHERS
THAT HAVE LEFT THROUGH.
OUT THE YEARS TO TAKE JOBS
CLOSER TO HOME TO COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD. TO BUY A
HOUSE AND BUT THE STATE IS NOT
GOING TO ADJUST FUNDING TO ALLOW
IT DISTRICT LIKE DAVIS TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN TEACHERS AS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
THEN I WOULD ASK FOR THE ABILITY
OF THE COMMUNITY OF DAVIS.
I CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT TO PUT
MORE MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF
TEACHERS --
AND NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY --
IN WHICH THEY LIVE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR TONY TRIGGER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE FIRST WELL ONE
APPRECIATE ALL THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS.
WE BELIEVE THAT GIVEN THE
TEMPORARY NATURE OF THE BILL IN
THE SUNSET THIS IS JUST A
SINGULAR TOOL.
AND A MUCH LARGER TOOL BOX THAT
WILL ADDRESS BOTH THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE AND A HOUSING CRISIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR AN IPO [inaudible]
Q..
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SIMILAR TO A CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
SO WE HAD SOME AMENDMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE BUT WE DO NOT HAVE
A RESPONSE FROM YOU ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE YOU TAKE ARE YOU TAKING AIM
AT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OR WE
WILL SO I WAS I MEAN I READ THE
ANALYSIS I WASN'T IT'S IT'S
CLEAR IF THOSE WERE SUGGESTED
MEANT IT AS IT RELATES THE FIRST
ISSUE.
WE CAN HAVE AN ISSUE WITH IT
SEEMS VERY CLEAR PRIMARY
RESIDENTS OF COURSE IT'S THE
SECOND ONE THAT I'M NOT NOT THAT
I'M SAYING I'M NOT OPEN TO OR WE
WOULD BE OPEN TO IT'S JUST THAT.
I I I WOULD NEED TO UNDERSTAND
REALLY HOW THAT IT WOULD BE
DRAFTED.
TUB KNOW WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN
EVEN DO IT [inaudible]
AT HAND.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WHATEVER THE
ANALYSIS THAT ENOUGH ADMIT MADAM
CHAIR I IT LOOKS LIKE THOSE WERE
SUGGESTIONS.
IT DIDN'T LOOK LIKE CLEAR CUT
NOBODY EVER FOR MY STAFF FOR ME
THAT.
YOU E. YOU WANT OF THESE HAVE AS
AMENDMENTS AT THE FIRST ONE IS
--
MISTER FERNANDEZ'S INDICATED I
THINK IT IS IT IS AS A PROBLEM I
THINK THE SECOND.
ONE IS PROBLEMATIC BUT NO.
THERE HAS BEEN IS COMMUNICATION
I THINK WE'VE REACHED OUT TRAVIS
BUT WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL WHAT
WE'LL DO IS WE WILL.
VOTE ON IT WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENTS --
AND WE'LL WORK IT YEAH WILL VOTE
ON IT WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS OF
THAT MISSILE WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL THE CITIZENS COMMITTEE TO
THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMAN I'LL MAKE A
COMMITMENT RIGHT NOW THIS
THING'S GOING WHERE NO.
WELL IT WAS ON THE FLOOR WORK ON
BUT IT.
OKAY WILK WILL WORK WITH THE
STAFF ON THIS IS I THINK THE FOR
THE FIRST ONE IS A LOT OF IT IS
IS NO PROBLEM.
THE SECOND ONE WE LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF ON TO ALRIGHT
MAKE SURE IT'S IT WILL WORK IN
THE FRAMEWORK OKAY.
WITH HIGHLY COLORED.
THE MACHINE CAN.
DO PASS BURKE.
BURKE I'M RO.
RO NO CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S MELINDA SNOW
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NOT VOTING
QUIRK NOT VOTING REAVIS
[inaudible]
RIVERSIDE TING.
TING AYE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
--
COLLAPSING TEASE.
CALENDAR WERE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENTEES ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CALENDAR IN THIS HIGHLY
COOLEY ABSENTEES.
FILE ITEM SIX S. B. FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN GREAT.
GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
MISTER TING CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
KING I IT.
OUT MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I OH OH
OH OH GOT IT --
VIOLATED BY OTHERS TO BE
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE CALL THE
ABSENTEES.
THAT WILL ONLY HAVE ABSENTEES ON
NUMBER TWO WE DID.
ITEM BY ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
NINE TWENTY FOUR HOUR CALL THE
ABSENTEES GRAIN.
GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING NOT VOTING.
LIVING A FILE ITEM.
FIVE SP THIRTEEN NINETY TO
MISTER MOLYNEAUX NUMBER.
FILE ITEM FOR ITS BE TEN  --
SEVEN COOLEY ABSENTEES MULLIN
[inaudible]
MULLIN I WE A FILE ITEM FIVE S.
B. THIRTEEN HATE FOR HER HAVE.
CALL THE ABSENCE YOU PRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TEAM [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
SAID.
THANK YOU ALL REVENUE TAX